le magic meeting c'est une visite
spectacle dans laquelle vous allez avoir
un casque sur vos la promenade
interactive va pouvoir commencer il n'y
aura plus aucune parole échangée entre
les deux guides et les visiteurs seule
une voie dans le casque leur donnera la
marche à suivre cette voie va mener
normalement les personnes étaient
présentes à faire des choses un petit
peu délirante car voilà on aime bien
nous quand le canton les gens se
rencontrent vraiment donc on essaye de
sortir un peu de la de la visite
classique pour créer un outil un
événement convivial red deer pour
information sous clovis il y a tellement
de pèlerins ici même que la bise de
saint-martin et donc tour a obtenu le
droit de battre monnaie c'est à dire de
créer une monnaie appelée le livre
tournoi
cinq ans
les anecdotes historiques sont bien
présentes mais elles s'achèvent toujours
en mode de musique décalée et en
indications plus ou moins farfelues les
visiteurs se prête volontiers au jeu
sous l'oeil amusé des badauds c'est
parti pour un air guitar lui connaît
j'adore danser et je trouve qu'on
devrait être payé pour faire l'animation
dans la ville de tours très très sympa
bien et voilà quand on aime le chantait
et dansait effectivement ça ça fait du
bien
moi j'ai beaucoup apprécié parce que ça
dans sa bouche en même temps on découvre
les choses et en plus le soleil était là
donc fait le faites le et ses yeux et
c'est génial
les prochains rendez-vous à la tour
charlemagne pour une déambulation
burlesque sont fixées au jeudi 6 à 18
heures et samedi 8 à 11 ans